Speaker 1: We continue to explore the overlap
between extreme right wing ism and mental
illness.
And this is a link that we can also find on
the extremes on the left as well.
But it's particularly notable lately on the
right.
And I have for you today, I'm going to present
to you a new character.
This is Susan Dilemmas.
Susan Dilemmas is a New Hampshire state representative.
She, in the wake of the forthcoming Roe v
Wade decision from the Supreme Court that
we learned about last week.
Protests broke out all over the country and
Representative Susan Delmas showed up at the
New Hampshire State House and started screaming
at the top of her lungs, I'm a murderer.
I murdered my own baby.
And this is serious and tragic.
And it also looks like a Saturday Night Live
skit, quite frankly.
It's both.
It's sad and it's endlessly hysterical in
a way.
So I'm going to play this for you.
She showed up and she started admonishing
the pro-choice protesters, calling them murderers
and calling herself a murderer.
Check this out.
So now she's screaming, shame on all of you.
But then she turns the anger inward.
You your.
I.
So I mean, it's impossible not to laugh at
the absurdity of this.
And also, tragically, she seems like a very
unwell person.
And this is a real challenge we have right
now.
We have to be sympathetic.
To severe illness, mental illness, without
diagnosing anyone ever.
Of course we never do that.
And at the same time realized that there is
political strength behind this nutter.
I'll give you another example.
We looked yesterday at this anti-vax stuff
where Michael Flynn and some guy named Clay,
I believe his name was were talking about
how there are how do I even explain this?
There are particles injected into the body
in the COVID vaccine, which then are which
contain Marburg virus, which is a filovirus
in the family of Ebola they inject you with.
It's almost like standby particles of the
Marburg virus and then a 5G signal pulsed
three times in a minute will activate the
particles which are on standby, and then you
will get Marburg virus.
That's so crazy.
You have to laugh at that.
That's absurd.
It's just it's comical.
It's a comical conspiracy theory.
But also, we have to recognize that seems
like mental illness.
And it's a tough thing to do.
I don't know what else can be said.
But whatever Susan Dilemmas went through or
is going through.
Um.
Hopefully she can get the help she needs.
I mean, I'm struggling with how to even say
this, but a new hero, I guess, of the.
Anti-choice movement.
I mean, I'm struggling for the language with
which we can really address this properly,
but bizarre and many anti-choicers saying
that's the kind of passion we need.
And when I see that, I see a very, very sick
person.
Let me know what you think.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
If you have thoughts, don't feel obligated.
You don't have to comment on every story.
I also want to remind you that Memorial Day,
Monday, May 30, Memorial Day, we are doing
a one day membership blowout to officially
kick off the primary season.
We are the midterm.
Rather, we will be beyond many primaries by
then.
We are primarily funded by our audience.
We want to do everything.
We want to cover the debates.
We want to cover rallies.
We're going to have someone on the ground
at the Trump rally this weekend.
All of these different things, all of these
different things cost money.
And so we depend on your support.
If you've been thinking, well, maybe I'll
sign up.
I don't hate David so much that I wouldn't
support him.
Right.
Get on my mailing list at David Pakman dot
com.
And then Monday, Memorial Day, you'll get
an email telling you how to sign up at an
ungodly discount